you were just on a conference call with
your analysts and investors saying that
this year you're going to overtake
Sprint as the number three wireless
carrier in the country I want you to
make an even bolder prediction what's
the boldest thing you can say about
what's gonna happen to t-mobile this
year you know more importantly if you
listen closely I actually said very
subtly and gently we already passed them
oh but I but I've been kind of gracious
you know not really one to brag so never
yeah I was I was kind of subtly rolling
that out and I think this is an
important challenge that you lay out
because we we just finished a great
quarter but the biggest growth year in
the history of the company with 8.3
million net additional customers and
four million postpaid phone Nets and we
took e ready we took 100 percent of the
phone net ads and the post paid side in
the whole industry so what you're gonna
see is 2015 is again a big
transformational year at the end of the
year we will have completed out 300
million pops of LTE and rapid deployment
of the 700 band and a migration the
1,900 of our 2g to 4G and we'll be
preparing for the lobe and spectrum
auctions in early 16 which together you
can envision the startup t-mobile will
now be on the cusp of not only being the
fastest growing wireless company which
we already are but duplicating and
exceeding any kind of wireless footprint
that AT&T or Verizon have and I don't
think that they're prepared to think
that way John let's talk about that
spectrum auction coming up the last
auction went for forty five billion
dollars total that was about four times
what anybody had thought how deeper your
pockets because you really need the low
band spectrum that's coming up yeah it's
a great point we bid in the auctions we
spent one point seven seven billion it
got a hundred and fifty one licenses in
areas that we needed we had the biggest
mid band spectrum portfolio of anybody
going into the auction so it wasn't
extremely important for us but what
what's happening in the industry and in
Washington is I would call auctions
there was this auction and this the
coming in
of option in the lobe and spectrum and
what the country and the government
wanted to accomplish one is fundraising
for public safety aspects etc and two is
to ensure competition which that's what
this is will continue